is it hard to put yourself out there
because you're used to hiding behind
yeah Instagram and all people are like
windows girl with no job stopping when
does Claudia start samuel l.jackson what
he followed me for like four years now I
want to move forward in like a really
positive way and like do good things
with it and like highlight good causes
and just like not be a piece of which I
think I was being before I definite
something oh no I googled eho Oh God
and I realized how young you were oh
yeah
and I feel so inadequate you know what's
so funny is coming from the digital
space like I'm a grandmother I'm 24 and
then when I hang out with like you
everyone's like you're so young I mean
nobody tells me that anymore I used to
be told I was young all the time nobody
says it anymore but at 24 years old
you're married you run a successful
business you're on tour you have one of
the most famous IDs in the world how did
that all come to you in less than three
years it's not less than three years so
I started girl with no job when I was a
freshman in college that was 2012 mm-hmm
and I've only really been popular at it
for like three or four years but it's
been a grind for a long time and I went
to a really rigorous dual curriculum
high school so I was used to being in
school from like 7:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m.
it is long known I got to college it was
like all day nothing to do so I got an
internship in fashion which you know
it's just like not my area of expertise
oh we can say we're they're ruthless
those [ __ ] like they're mean they're
skinny and it's just like all the
offices they make it so hot and I
started a blog on tumblr where we just
like talked about the people who were so
mean to me at work and just like the
trials and tribulations of being an
unpaid intern I got fired obviously like
I was the world's worst intern I was
like I'm gonna pick my blog back up
again you know
then the og blog was called girl with a
job but then they didn't have a job at
the time so I changed it to girl with no
job I wanted it to be accurate you know
and I think the name had had a lot to do
with the success it like catches girls
no job and people like old people who
meet me are another confused by what I
do they're like you don't have a job oh
my god you like I have a job um I guess
I'm very busy
yes when did you know that girl with no
job was something I'm shallow and vain
so like when celebrities started
following me and I've always been like
really in
in pop culture the first person to
following Joe Jonas no and like I've
always had a special place in my heart
for him after that and he was my
favorite Jonas brother obviously that
was when I was like oh real people are
taking note and then when I first
started getting paid I was like oh this
is legit who was like the most
surprising samuel l.jackson what I
believe he has since unfollowed me but
he followed me for like four years
did he ever slam udm never and so I know
that when I have the opportunity to DM a
celebrity I need to be reasonable like I
can't be thirsting enough they're gonna
unfollow me if I'm always jamming them
so I wait for the right moment you know
Harry Styles follows me and you bet my
ass like I definitely got up in the DMS
with him 100% well I went to his concert
and I just like tagged him in an
Instagram I'm like haha
we actually met a celebrity on the same
weekend okay which one Gwyneth she was
on my top three to like run into a yoga
unfortunately I don't go any places
where when it goes cuz I don't juice and
I don't work out like unless I'm seeing
her at McDonald it's like it's not gonna
happen so it was really grateful to get
the opportunity cuz I never thought it
was gonna happen to you you know and I
think her and I like really connected
and I'm maybe I'm just like you know
living in a fantasy world and that's
very possible but if you like I really
got to know her you don't I mean and you
know people have a lot to say about her
I think people think she's like
pretentious the conscious uncoupling
whatever but just getting to hang out
with her and her kids like homegirl is
legit what's the three things that
people have to have to emulate your
success like what do you think like the
IG has to write I think it has to have
good intentions I know that sounds weird
but it's like people are actively now
being like I want to get followers I
want to get brands I want to get money
and want people to follow me on people
to let me take pictures with me and
that's legit cool it would so
inauthentic you know I thought is gonna
blow up at some point it has to like I
feel like it's about it's like the
housing market exactly I think what's
this tour like it's legit I feel like
going on a comedy tour would be the most
terrifying thing in don't worry you
don't understand I'm so brave like I
used to watch comedians in cars you ever
watch that Netflix show and Jerry
Seinfeld's always talking about
comedians like their firefighters like
they're the bravest most important
people in our nation on my cherry you're
dramatic but having been a comedian now
for over a year I'm like we are brave
you know it's really scary and
I have the privilege it that most
comedians don't have of playing to an
audience who know me already like I
didn't start out on open mics you know
just doing the grind which is really
hard but it helps you build the muscle
and build like this self-esteem to do it
you just ran into the Olympics without
any training exactly and I'm so grateful
for my followers for just showing up the
first few shows like they were rough I'm
not gonna lie it's like playing piano
we're riding a bike whatever it is you
got to practice yeah and practicing in
front of a full house is hard people on
the internet are sensitive and they want
to feel heard and they don't want to be
upset so comedies the exact opposite
it's like we don't give up if you're mad
we think this is funny and I'm in a
weird position being in the middle so I
try really my stuff is not crazy it's
not offensive it's usually about myself
I'm making fun of myself because I can't
offend anyone if I'm calling myself the
chubby Jew I'm relatable well hopefully
is it hard to put yourself out there
because you're used to hiding behind
yeah my Instagram handle you know I love
it cuz I feel like sometimes people from
the internet don't translate so it's
like they've gotten successful off of
hiding behind a keyboard and then it
comes in real life and they have a mean
greed and they're awkward and I hear
about it all the time so I'm really
conscious of that I feel like exactly
who I am on Instagram is exactly who I
am in real life I feel like I'm even
more extra in realize yeah people are
like when does girl with no job stop and
when does Claudia start I'm like no rich
we're the same I am fascinated by how
quick we as a society want to cancel
people meet you cancel culture as a
thing and unfortunately for you I was
momentarily cancelled what was going
through your mind the moment you woke up
and that was happening it was a really
really dark for days and it just never
ended you know it was like article
article tweet tweet and I'm the type of
person when people are talking about me
like I can't turn it out I always read
my comments I like to see what people
are saying about me good and bad but the
volume and and the magnitude of it was
so big and I I just couldn't stop
reading stuff which is the worst thing
you can do cuz like hearing people say
the most horrible evil vile things about
you and they feel justified in doing
that in the world makes them think it's
okay to do it it was really hard like
and I'm not trying to make myself a
victim or anything but like nobody
deserves that
you know I defended you because I felt
that you were not in the wrong and I
feel like the cancer culture is so quick
and so instantaneous but was there ever
a moment in there were
you thought that you were gonna give up
I thought the world was sad with me and
I was kind of done with the world - you
know I was really like thinking about
just not working here anymore because I
can't handle it
like I was really broken I'm like I
don't think I could I don't want this
for myself if I'm gonna have kids do I
want to put them through this I don't
think so
I would like to go through a list of
people who are on the brink of being
cancelled and I want to know from you
can they come back from what they're
going yeah cuz I feel like cancel
culture is terrible but there are
definitely people are Kelly who need to
be cancelled but we've sort of just
started lumping people together like
Kevin Hart is not a murderer
he made a bad joke yeah a very bad joke
and but he handled it poorly of course
but I don't loop him in the same basket
as louis c.k was showing his dick to
girls like you know what I mean
doing something and saying something are
two very different things I totally
agree with you I really breaking the law
is one thing making a bad joke is a
whole other thing first person up for
cancellation the Jessie's mileage show
pace badge canceled it's my personal
belief that like he was definitely
involved and it's really unethical so I
mean I don't I don't know if he will be
cancelled but I think he probably should
be do you think he can come back from
this
no it's really bad I feel like nobody in
the world knew who Jesse's smell it was
before and now everyone knows who he is
in a really negative way I'd rather go
to jail and have everyone think I'm
innocent then get off and I've everyone
think I'm guilty [ __ ] I will do my time
yeah I mean I feel are gonna be really
popular oh I'd be an Aryan Brotherhood
into Vegas oh you gotta protect me I'm
gonna be your publisher I was very
quickly like climb the food chain and
become like head [ __ ] in charge
Olivia Jade ah no she didn't do anything
you know her parents are blood on their
hands and did something illegal but
she's just a kid why can't normal people
world is divided this entire thing
triggered a lot of people on celebrities
and privileged thinking that they're
better than everyone and cutting the
line but at the same time we let them
think that we give them spent like we
make them into these huge stars I'm
gonna get mad when they do things that
normal stars do her mom was probably
just like take this picture and you do
what your parents tell you when you're
in high school okay she's living under
her mom's roof her mom says fill this
out okay Jordan would know I mean I
think Kylie
cancel her but I don't think the world
should you know exactly she didn't do
anything illegal she just made a mistake
a drunk mistake which might add is so
sad because how many drunk nights have
you had where you may be yelled at
someone or kiss someone or did something
bad and imagine if the entire world was
watching you being so nice about that
and I kissed someone or yelled at
someone [ __ ] I was reading people to
fail and I was doing the grown-up
well maybe you deserve to be canceled
that's what we call it listen going
through what you went through coming out
of it that bigger and better what would
you say to somebody who is in your
similar shoes like Olivia Jade handle it
right you know because I totally owned
the fact that I ducked and that people
were really hurt by things that I said
and I always apologize because what I do
my point on this earth is to make people
laugh so if something I said ever upset
you like I'm never gonna stop
apologizing for that cuz that's
literally the antithesis of why I get
out of bed you know I mean I thought I
was shouting into a void until you do
something bad and everyone who's ever
heard of your name speaks ill of you
half the people who are writing about me
that was the first time they ever wrote
about me I'm like [ __ ] where was all
this press when I was doing cool things
you know like nobody cared until I made
a mistake and it was really like a
surreal horrifying nightmare so I really
realized how big and an influential my
platform was and now I want to move
forward in like a really positive way
and like do good things with it and like
highlight good causes and just like not
be a piece of which I think I was being
before yeah I paid like a really public
price but also a really private one that
I kind of just like took really
seriously you know I'm like if I'm gonna
come back I don't want to be like
another washed-up bad tweets moment like
I want to do it in an impactful way and
really just come back stronger I feel
like what happened with with my story is
kind of relatable like the people who
follow me are similar age to me so we
all kind of grew up and in high school
times like Facebook and Twitter we're
popping off yeah and it's an important
lesson to be learned like you can say
something or write something and then 10
years later see it and feel horrified by
it and HR might call you and be like we
got to talk to you about this thing it's
a real issue and I feel like I'm weirdly
became like the spokesperson for it and
I'm more than happy to do that because
it's an important lesson to be learned
like what you say has implication and
you don't realize how much influence you
have until something that happens you're
absolutely right you know the first
I started working here they were like yo
we need you to delete like four of these
to you I say you don't even remember
writing it I don't have no recollection
I was a different person I did reverse I
was in this like bubble I went to
college and met like new people who
weren't like just Jewish kids you know
what he and you your life changes so
much in five or ten years that I don't
even remember that person yeah and by
the way mine weren't that terrible they
were shirtless photos this is to
Thursday like what am I supposed to be
in a burqa on the beach like I'm gonna
vote for four weeks that is uncanny boo
the bike rack is cool in Hollywood you
have Hollywood friends and then you have
friend friends and you don't realize who
your Hollywood friends are and who your
real friends are until you go through
something yes what was it like figuring
out who those people were for you when
it comes to people in the industry
everyone wants something from you and I
knew that and I've always been really
good about not making like real
friendships with people who I just don't
have a good feeling about yeah and I
didn't find really that so many people
were were like distancing themselves for
me because I never let them in do you
know yeah because I know I watch a lot
of Kardashians like this industry and
this town is and I never wanted to be
the person who got like Jordan woods to
like Jordan Wood says nobody she got cut
off she got cut off and she didn't have
any real friends to stick by her except
for Jada for sure but if you slept with
my baby daddy
no you can have the convenience let me
tell you you need medical treatment that
happened when I was living my best life
waking up in you know you know friends
houses and being 23 you worries oh yeah
you got married at 23 yes I got engaged
when I was 21 mm aeronauts 23 you knew
yeah I mean me and Ben by the time we
got married we were together for like
five years already and I just didn't
want to wait I mean I could we both knew
what's with the song and dance is you
gonna do it do it just do it I have a
career to build I got I got things to do
yeah you're not looking for fresh D no I
love the G you love the D I love B's G
but wait what happened
you're on tour because listen you've
been on this sold-out tour you're busy
is there like some facetime nipa is
there like a sexy mo man in this day and
age you can't like that I've actually
never in my life sent a nude photo like
even to my husband like because it's so
dangerous wait you kidding the treasured
husband no it's not that it's the cloud
I don't even see why nipples are you
crazy I don't like that I'm about to
turn my cloud off and start doing only
green text messages I I don't blame you
I would send a pigeon
yes very Game of Thrones events in a
pigeon - like what's the courier the
courier I wasn't a courier with like a
nude sketch I'm face duty myself in the
sketch I'm like bring my weight my waist
in a little cut the cellulite perk up
the tip are you ever going to have kids
of course I'm talking to someone and
he's like don't have kids I'm like yeah
he's wet when I make me like when I'm 25
and he goes aren't you turning 25 to two
months and I was like oh never mind now
I'm like 27 I just it does change your
life and it changes your priorities and
I don't think I'm done yet you know any
means yeah and it sucks that like the
world is like it doesn't think a woman
can be a CEO and a mom but it's hard and
I feel like my priorities are gonna
change I'm just gonna I mean I already
have a dog and I have the hardest time
leaving my dog on tour so I can only
imagine that's gonna be heightened a
little bit with a child yeah thank you
so much for being here
like what you saw hit subscribe you
don't want to miss any new episodes or
just to sit and you can catch up on any
past episodes the tea was hot I'm
telling you